[Music]
straight ahead
online crime daily 14 firings and
suspensions at fort hood
following the investigation into the
murder of army specialist vanessa
guillen
a message to female soldiers who say
they too have been sexually assaulted
if any of them see this i want them to
know we believe you
olivia jade speaks out about the
criminal case against her parents
actress lori laughlin and designer
masamo gianouli but is her apology
enough
plus should evidence in the case against
members of a family
accused of killing a mother be thrown
out what led investigators to find her
body parts
buried on the suspect's property there
was a presence of human
remains lawn crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the u.s army announced sweeping changes
following an investigation
into the murder of one of their own
specialist vanessa guillen was
bludgeoned to death inside fort hood
texas
earlier this year she disappeared on
april 22nd and her dismembered remains
were found on june 30th
the suspect in the case specialist aaron
robinson killed himself the next day
as police were attempting to arrest him
his girlfriend cecily aguilar is accused
of assisting him
gillane's family says she had been
sexually harassed by an unnamed sergeant
at fort hood
but complaints against the sergeant were
dismissed
the murder of specialist vanessa guillen
shocked our conscient
conscience and brought attention to
deeper problems
the initial investigation into vanessa's
death coupled with high numbers of
crimes
and deaths at fort hood has revealed
a series of missteps and multiple
failures in our system
and within our leadership i am gravely
disappointed
that leaders failed to effectively
create a climate that treated all
soldiers
with dignity and respect and that failed
to reinforce everyone's obligation
to prevent and properly respond to
allegations of sexual harassment
and sexual assault because of this
to restore trust and confidence and
accountability
i've directed the relief and or
suspension of commanders
and other leaders from the corps to the
squad level
an independent committee spoke with
soldiers and allowed them to speak
openly about their concerns
the individual interviews especially
were pretty revealing
uh we interviewed 500 of the 647
503 were female soldiers what we found
was that there was a fear of retaliation
all forms of retaliation stigmatism
ostracism
career derailing a career
assignments work assignments and that
sort of thing
there was there was a fear and a founded
fear
that the confidentiality of the
reporting process would be compromised
um there was a fear or there was a lack
of of any
appreciation for the results or the
response because
it took so long to get an adjudication
that people that never saw the
adjudication so they lost
they lost faith in that the committee
found a shocking number of credible
claims of sexual assaults
that were never reported
as you mentioned 503 of the 647 were
women we made a very concerted effort to
interview every single woman within
specific units
in particular the unit that vanessa gian
belonged to
and what we did discover was
which was one of the really shocking um
elements or parts of of the interview
period
where the number of unreported sexual
harassment and sexual assault
incidents of the 503 women that we
interviewed we discovered 93
credible accounts of sexual assault
of those only 59 were reported and we
also found
135 i'm sorry 217
unreported accounts of sexual harassment
and so that's a really significant
number of those
just over half were reported and so what
we discovered during the course of those
interviews is that due to the lack of
confidence in the system that lack of
confidence absolutely
affected affects the reporting of those
incidents
joining me now are attorneys deena daw
along with terry austin
terry those numbers were shocking when
you think of the numbers of reports and
and when they put in that word credible
um
claims that's that's pretty big to me
but 14
fired or suspended after the
investigation including commanders and
low-level leaders
do you think this cures the cancer or do
you think more needs to happen
to cure this toxic culture brian i think
so much more needs to happen this was a
140-page report that's pretty long
and you heard the comments there by army
secretary ryan mccarthy
that this was a thorough investigation
but i think it
uncovered some systemic weaknesses in
the system
so for instance female soldiers they
were retaliated against
when they reported the sexual harassment
so i think what we are going to need to
do there is
institute some safeguards into the
system so that
for instance people can report to an
outside third party said they don't have
to deal with
this sort of retaliation that apparently
is going on
within the army and other branches of
our services
all right so dina a little over a dozen
people get fired or suspended
but do you think there are potential
criminal or civil cases that could stem
out of these terminations either by the
victims or the victims families
yes absolutely you know on behalf of the
women because there were
crimes here that were committed i think
it's really important that they did this
investigation and it's a good first step
because
the a victim here is a lot more
vulnerable than they would be normally
because the military is an enclosed
bubble they have their own criminal
justice system
they have as you see their own reporting
if somebody wants to
take this on as their career there's not
a lot of other places they can go so
it's very important that the military
itself
cleans itself up and protects these
victims because
they have maybe even less of a chance to
get
justice and within this system with it
so close
yeah and i think we can all agree when
it comes to the military we shouldn't be
using the word less
when it comes to the concept of safety
security and dignity for our men and
women who are serving this country
i hope that this this push to give them
more transparency and more protection
continues
thank you both and now to ohio where law
and crime's angenette levy has details
on an unusual case
a strange smell coming from an apartment
in cincinnati led police to a man's body
at this point it's not clear exactly how
long that body had been hidden
kenya stallsworth and robert robb are
charged with abuse of a corpse
court documents say a john doe died in a
bedroom of an apartment
and robin stallsworth covered the body
with clothes to hide it
and then tried to seal the room to keep
the smell of decomposition inside
the coroner's office is not commenting
on the identity of the man or the cause
of death
but more charges could be coming for law
and crime daily
i'm internet levy still ahead on law and
crime
daily federal authorities investigate
the death of a man
killed by police in ohio but first
the daughter of actress lori laughlin
speaks out for the first time
about the college admissions scandal
welcome back an update in the college
admissions scandal involving actress
lori laughlin
terry austin has more
jade spoke publicly for the first time
about her parents arrest
and not all were pleased laughlin and
her husband designer massimo
gionouli pleaded guilty to paying 500
000
to get their two daughters into the
university of southern california
olivia the younger daughter had been
posting on social media
about wanting to party rather than go to
class
she apologized on the web series red
table talk hosted by jada pinka smith
we had the means to do something and we
completely took it and ran with it and
it was something that was wrong
and i think what a lot of people not
that it matters because nothing that
happened was
it really can't be excused like on paper
it's bad
it's really bad but i think what a lot
of people don't know is
my parents came from a place of just i
love my kids i just want to help my kids
whatever is best for them i i worked my
whole life to
you know provide for my family and i
think they thought it was
normal right um and i think that
there was a college counselor involved
who seemed legitimate and ended up not
being legitimate
and in that community it was it was it
was not out of the ordinary
right and it's it's embarrassing to say
that i didn't know
now terry no questions let's just talk
uh
we know each other personally i know
you're a mother who has put kids through
college i'm still surprised at that but
you're i got to take your word for it
how do you react when you hear that this
is how other people are putting their
kids through college
you know brian i actually have mixed
feelings here you know for many years i
was a single mom and you know putting
children through
college is a lot of work and we were
definitely
not privileged and i worked very hard we
all did to make sure that our children
had a good education so i totally
understand feeling resentment towards
people like olivia and her parents
i mean how can you be so blind to
injustices
and systemic racism that absolutely
permeates
nearly every institution here in the
united states but i will say
this having said that i do think this
was a step
in the right direction at some point we
all need to face the truth and we all
need to make amends and i think
olivia tried to do that by going on
the you know red table talk so i you
know kudos to her
for trying to make this step and i just
hope and pray that she continues to take
these types of steps
towards redemption
now dina you're kind of in a similar
boat i know you have a son who's a
sophomore so you're
eyeing college in the future what are
your thoughts
you know it just seemed like the timing
was off for one thing because
students across america are dealing with
education inequality
with this online schooling and so people
are really
suffering not even just at the college
level but every level
so for her to come on with just like a
simple apology that she didn't know
better to me just being
too little maybe she could have come out
with some sort of platform that she was
working on
or waited and give an apology when
people are all kind of in a little bit
of a better spot
the fact of the matter is that yes this
probably has been going on for a long
time but it is wrong
and it just to me it just seems like
the wrong time for us to really care so
much about what she personally was going
through which is what she seemed to want
us to do
yeah um my two cents here is
i i think most people who know me i was
a college athlete i worked two jobs i
cleaned the tennis courts at night and i
cut the grass on the old soccer field
where i was actually an all-american
so i didn't get a lot of that and my
mother was the one who put me through
college on her own
and so really i feel more disgusted for
her than anything else but
that's just my two cents i think
everyone can bring their own opinion to
this one i think that's what's so great
about this story
thank you both for contributing coming
up on law and crime daily why the death
of a man shot by police is ruled a
homicide
authority says he was not the suspect
they were looking for
plus we take you inside the courtroom
where members of a family accused of
murder are asking for evidence against
them to be thrown out
those cases after the break
[Music]
now to an update in a police shooting
federal authorities say they'll review
the shooting death of an ohio man killed
by a deputy
the franklin county coroner ruled casey
goodson's junior's death a homicide
the autopsy said he died from multiple
gunshot wounds to the torso
the deputy was on assignment with the
u.s marshal's fugitive task force
looking for a suspect who was not
goodson law enforcement officials say
good son was waving a gun
but his family says he was carrying a
sandwich bag and was walking into his
home
when he was shot terry
the investigation haven't given us much
yet but the most shocking account that
i've heard so far
from the family is that he was shot in
the back and fell into his home
his keys were still in the door to me
that sounds like he wasn't a threat to
the officers
what are your thoughts you know i agree
with you he wasn't a threat at least
based on what we are hearing
you know the family also said he was
carrying a sandwich and he wasn't
carrying
a gun and the shooting occurred in front
of the grandmother and two
toddlers so if he's trying to enter the
house there are other people obviously
they could have gotten shot or even
killed and so
i think that i'm concerned about this
shooting
and it took place five days ago you know
the autopsy report is
oddly vague it doesn't say what the
trajectory of the bullets were so
i'm a little concerned that you know
there might be some
hidden you know things going on here so
at this point we need all of the details
about these bullets and what exactly
happened at this shooting
agreed and even the autopsy is very
scant with information
it says torso it doesn't say the front
the back
and while that might be small that is a
big distinction when it comes to use of
force
for officers dina from what i'm
understanding this officer didn't have
body camera
the report is saying that there are no
other officers as witnesses
and the family is merely kind of not
saying that they saw it firsthand
it literally sounds like a he said now
he's dead situation
is this a hard type of case to prosecute
if they're looking to go after the
officer
i think it will be key to decide whether
or not they can figure out if the
bullet wounds weren't from the back or
the front that will help quite a bit in
the trial
i mean even assuming the police
officer's account that he was waving
a gun i think this is an excellent
example of how we need the de-escalation
because again we have somebody who's
killed for something
that is not criminal or if that is it's
a
very small crime so how this went from
even if he weighs a gun to him being
shot
and killed multiple times in the torso
this is why this kind of case is being
brought
national attention and they're having a
federal civil investigation
as a result of it
exactly and by all accounts he was a
registered gun owner and had a
uh carrying concealed permit so it's not
that he was carrying the gun illegally
from our understanding
uh thank you both when we come back a
mother missing
then found dead on the property
performer in-laws
in the deadly custody dispute next
and now to a hearing in florida where
attorneys for three members of a family
charge in a murder of a florida mother
are trying to get evidence
thrown out of their case nicole montalvo
disappeared last year after dropping her
son off at the home of her estranged
husband
christopher otero rivera he and his
father angel avera
are charged with murder his mother wanda
rivera
is charged with being an accessory the
defense says investigators initially
obtained a search warrant for a missing
person's case
but a deputy's k-9 partner found the
victim's dismembered remains
on the properties owned by the riveras
as we began searching he started showing
changes in behavior
that there was a presence of human
remains
somewhere nearby the wind was
the wind was strong that day and
he kept air scenting raising his head
trying to figure out where it was coming
from
we searched one side of the properly
property there were some holes and some
smoothed out earth that
the detectives really wanted to hit
first
so as we did that he kept air scenting
and wanting to go
behind the property to the adjacent
property there was a fence line and a
ditch
he kept wanting to go back there and go
back there
that piece of property was not
we didn't know who owned it yet so we
couldn't go search it
um so after he he got tired
he was put back in the truck and passed
my findings along that
he was wanting to get somewhere but i'm
not sure where yet
the victim's mother said she went to her
daughter's apartment complex
looking for her with the help of the
detectives
we were still standing outside waiting
to get into her apartment
we were trying to determine if she was
inside or not
and um detective miller had come back
because there was saint cloud there and
also osceola
detective miller had come back and he
was talking
walking towards me with his phone and he
said we received a text message
that angel got from nicole
and i said can you tell me how the
spelling is
he said it was a lengthy one text
message and i said can you tell me what
the spelling and stuff was like
and he said he was kind of like hesitant
on showing me
and i said because i'm telling you right
now this is the way my daughter texts
and i pulled up the text from sunday
night and i showed him and he said no
this isn't this is what i have did you
show it to you at that time then he
showed it to me and i said that's
absolutely not nicole
all right so this isn't a trial terry so
let me try to figure this out this is a
suppression here we're talking fourth
amendment search and seizure
they're trying to say that that right or
that constitutional right was violated
i don't really see it there though can
you walk us through how you think this
might play out
well you know brian the evidence is
going to be suppressed if the judge
believes that the evidence was obtained
illegally
and what defense counsel is arguing here
is that
the search of the family's home and
property they're saying it was illegal
because the detectives actually
misstated some of the details in the
affidavits
and one of those misstatements had to do
with whether or not this was a
kidnapping
or whether it was a missing person so if
the judge finds that
that affidavit was misleading it could
actually
you know keep the evidence suppressed
and that would be
very damaging to the prosecution's case
deena as i'm listening to this i'm
thinking and i don't want to get too in
the weeds with this
inevitable discovery the officer or the
pros going to say hey we would have
found this anyways and
and that keen nose from the canine unit
is what really led them to this
to this body what are your thoughts on
how this suppression hearing could play
out
i imagine that the judge will allow it
this evidence
and because as you said he would they
were going to discover it anyway and
that whether or not it was a kidnapping
or missing person
both would still be valid basis for the
search for it
but it's important for the defense
attorney to file this and the reason why
is because obviously without this
search all of this evidence wouldn't
have come in and this is where they
found the body
the whole case would go away so they
have to preserve
this issue for even just for appeal
because if they lose here and have a
trial
they'll still get a chance to appeal
this and say it wasn't adjudicated
properly
and so his if he is convicted that
should get thrown out
yeah i mean who was it michael jordan
who says you miss every shot you don't
take and as a defense attorney you've
got to take that shot
even if you think there's a likelihood
of it not being made in
of course we're going to keep following
this case i think the hearing results
the judge says will get
back to us in about a month uh i think
both of us or all three of us are
thinking that this will likely not get
suppressed is that right
uh dina and terry absolutely i think
it's going to be
yeah and then after that we just figure
out whether or not to guilt your
innocence questions
thank you very much for joining me
ladies and thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily
we will see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you